RFI Podcast
Sans rêve pas d'avenir...
Et l'afrofuturisme, c'est notre capacité
à réinventer notre futur,
que notre futur ne soit plus jamais uniquement celui imaginé par les autres.
Celui qu'il n'est pas en capacité
de se projeter dans le futur ne s'y trouvera pas !
Cette manière que l'Afrique d'aujourd'hui a
de se projeter dans un avenir, dans son avenir,
une manière de dire que l'avenir c'est
ce qu'elle va faire...
Et évidemment, il faut laisser galoper
l'imagination.
C'est le principe non seulement du Futurisme, c'est
également le principe de la prospective d'ailleurs.
Une bonne prospective c'est pas simplement prolonger mathématiquement des tendances aujourd'hui.
C'est également à un moment
donné de dire Rêvons un peu !